είναι πίσω αλλά είναι αξιωματική αντι πολύτευσης στην ελλά άρα τα κυπριακά κόματα ακόμα περισσότερο
και λόγομε γιέθου στης χώρας είχαν ακόματα δει οιδική μας συνήθως αντι γράφουν το ότι
γίνεται στην ελλάδα οι ελλάδα αντιγράφειται ότι γίνεται στην ιταλλία νη στην αγκλία αμα δεν
έβρηκαν κάπου αλού το κλειδί θα ήταν δύσκολο να το βρουν στην κύπροείναι πολύ μάκρια
από την νέαν από τους νέους τα πράδωση ακακόμματα και όχι μόνω τα κόματα της
σκύπρείναι είναι μεγάλη απόσταση εναι μεγάλο το χάσμα ποχωρίζει με τη νέα γένια ώστε να
τους πρόσεγγίσου και να τους πίσουν αύριο να πάνε να ψηφύσουν τα ξινομίζω ότι το
χάσμα δεν έχει να κάνει δεν είναι μόνο ιλικιακό σίγουρα ένας κάποιος οποίο σήμερα σήμερα
που μιλούμεν είναι δεκαεφτά χρονών του χρόνου έτι εποχή θα ψηφύζειή θα έχει το δικαίωμα
να ψηφύσεις τις βουλευτικές εκλογίας που αν παίρνω σε μια αρμοθεσια θα πόσα να ψεφίσων
αποταξίδα εκατάλαβα αποτέ όμως γιατί θέλαν να περάσουν τη νομοθεσία να πάμε να ψηφίζουμε με
είδεκαοκτάχρον οι δεκανιάχροοικοσάχρονοι τριαντάχρονι όχι μόνο δεψηφζουν δεν εγγράφονται κά των εκλογικών καταλόγο με το
εντούντες κινσεις που κάπνουν τα κόμματα που διείχνουν ότι δεν χουν ιδέα δεν εψάξαν και
όλας δεί αν πάμε στως δέκαεφτάχρονους ελύσαμε το πρόβλημα προσεγκήσαμε ι τους νέους καλύτερα τίποτε
εντυποσιασμός αυτές οι προτάσεις είναι καθαρά γοαρώτησης σήμερα δρέάμος δεκεφτάχνο σίουρα από τους πολιτικούς θα
ξετοφιρία έναν παράδειγμα μόνο το φύδιαμόνο το φιδί αν εκτώ ε άνο πατέρας του δεκαεφτάχρονού
ή μητέρα του ιγιαγιά του γιοπαπούς του ήταν κάποτες εναγκόμα πάειστο σύλλογο ξέρει των βουλευτή
του και ένας από τους λόγους που τα κόμματα είναι ακόμα εκεί είναι διότι ελέγχουν
σε κάποιο βαθμόν τις διευκολήσεις που γίνονται διότι για να έχεις πρόβλεμαμε θέλεις να πι
στον νοσοκομείω πιον ένα πιασις να σεκανονής ε να πιάσεις ενα βουλευτεί θέλεις